welcome back to the 69th ever episode of
the iced coffee podcast my name is ask
sebi and the podcast has made a hundred
and nine thousand dollars and five
hundred dollars that's great
what an intro we're gonna go with it
welcome to the iced coffee hour we're
really excited to have you on here i
don't believe you do too many podcasts
do you no not at all is this your first
one first podcast is there a reason why
you don't do so many podcasts are you
hiding
i don't know i just don't think i've
been invited to podcast because people
don't i'm not that interesting you know
what the surprising thing i think with
you is that uh i knew you from your
credit card videos on youtube
but then once i started talking to you i
realized like wow this is just the tip
of the iceberg of what you do like the
credit card thing i think i think if we
have a big like bubble basically the the
credit card stuff is like one little bit
and then you get into all the
intricacies of like what you do on the
side i think all of your side businesses
and the side investments that you're
doing are way more like interesting than
credit card stuff like tenfold it's
actually pretty unique i would love for
you to introduce yourself to the
audience for those that don't know you
like where did this start give us a bit
of like an overview of what you say you
do some of the startups you're involved
in the businesses that you run and just
we got to have a good hook 20 seconds
what's the hook so i used to work in
finance ended up moving into the startup
world started a company that raised
money died started another company that
raised money got acquired jumped around
a few different startups started angel
investing and before angel investing
started youtube actually mostly because
i figured that
content creation will be the future for
a lot of people and the whole creator
economy idea so by working in finance
what exactly did you do
so a lot of it was transaction services
so like m a stuff for tax
uh not the most interesting thing for a
podcast i think people are gonna click
off this if they if i keep talking well
how about this how was the money working
in finance doing stuff like that money
is good obviously but it's not as much
as
you would think if you compare it to
like content creation and just a lot of
other things where you can control your
own hours if like imagine working 100
hours a week yes you might get
maybe like 100 200 000 but there's so
many better ways to make that level of
money i think so you were working 100
hours a week yeah i think you work
pretty aggressively with most people was
just like right out of school that you
did really yeah how much of that is
networking though instead of grades
because i would imagine a lot of people
have great grades
but if they don't have the networking
skills they just never get in in the
first place yeah i think that's a a very
major thing especially for asian
students because people just assume that
you're like not social when you can't
network and that you're not fun to work
with so there are a lot of people who
have like really good grades 4.0 but
it's they don't get interviewed as much
as they should because there is that
merit side and then there's the like
social side of it got it okay so what
made you leave that industry of working
like a hundred hours a week how long did
you do that for as well
uh
two years um initially i think i got
dissuaded from working in the industry
and i was like oh let me work in tech
and i think it's a pretty common
thing for people where they're like okay
let me like reinvent myself let me work
in a different industry that's better
that like either pays more competitively
or that i can find my passion in so that
made a bit more sense to me
but i mean you're kind of trading 100
hour 100 hours a week getting paid very
well to working 100 hours a week not
getting paid very well especially if
you're trying to start your own company
got it so you saved up some money from
doing that for two years then decided to
do something you're more passionate
about and i'm sure you had some sort of
savings that you were able to live off
of while doing this first startup yep so
i pretty much cut my spend down to crazy
crazy levels just to make sure my runway
would be as long as possible i think
graham would be pretty impressed that's
right so i was spending about 500 a
month in boston
wow
that's including housing that was
including housing food what about health
insurance
oh
you don't need that
yeah called planet fitness
i'm certain certain things yeah you you
just maybe you should have paid for it
but you you skipped oh that's right i
didn't listen i didn't pay for health
insurance for
how many you told me about this yeah
yeah because i i figured like i looked
at the the statistics i was going to the
gym every day i didn't drink i didn't
smoke i don't like well i guess i have
car insurance obviously but health
insurance i had like no existing
conditions and when i got a quote for
myself i think i was like 25 26 whenever
you fall off your parents plan whatever
that is um i looked into it it was like
300 bucks a month and i'm thinking to
myself that's a that's a less payment
that's a lease payment and i never go to
well i should i should go to the doctor
but i never go to the doctor i was like
why like i'm just gonna take the chances
and if something happens i'll find a way
to pay for it out of pocket but yeah
didn't need it and then they issued the
penalty
when i think it was like one percent of
your salary is a penalty and then i was
like oh crap now i have to do it because
it's cheaper so you survived without it
and then they instituted this penalty
and then that's when you decided to yes
didn't you pay the penalty for a year
though i did yeah i think the first year
i was just so against it because i felt
like it was a waste of money and uh yeah
the first year i paid the penalty and
then the penalty went from one percent
to two percent i was like
i i hate i hate the penalty but you know
what it is what it is now i have health
insurance
which i have no i've never used uh the
two times i've actually gone to a doctor
i've decided to pay out of pocket
because i don't want to deal with the
insurance companies and my deductible is
so high it doesn't make sense anyway 500
a month is impressive uh what was your
living situation like how do you get
away with 500 bucks with
yeah so we were living a bit further
away but we could bike so i had like a
bike pass that was like an unlimited
bypass thing i had a co-working space
that was only 70 a month and they would
throw a lot of free events where you
could get free food so a lot of startups
are like hey we're doing this launch
event we're doing whatever here's free
pizza so i got a way of doing that quite
a bit for
probably like four months and then we
ended up getting into an accelerator
program down in rhode island where they
gave you money to invest in you and yeah
that got a bit better afterwards what
was the first business you said the
first one failed
yes what was that so that was trying to
help companies hire based off
myers-brigg which is kind of flawed and
not the best the myers break for anybody
who's not aware that's like the
introvert extrovert like right that they
give the four letters basically details
your personality on a sheet of paper
yeah yeah i feel like just depending on
your mood that day it could swing like
you could be an introvert one day and
extrovert the next you could fake it
really well as an introvert yeah and
then also you could argue it's like well
is there any hiring efficacy like is it
better is certain things actually better
or not but i think the idea was that it
was another data set that you would have
as a hiring person that just more data
is always better when you're trying to
hire could uh could i ever say that you
discriminated against me because i'm an
introvert no that uh no you can't do
that ironically not i think it would be
like oh engineers generally prefer
working with other introverts versus
extroverts because they don't like
getting distracted they don't want to
yeah i feel like there's some weight to
that you know like if you are hiring a
sales person it might make probably
someone more extroverted but i think we
got a lot of pushback from companies
that's like oh like how valid is this
yeah and there's also a lot of like
crappy science behind myers break as
well and everything else and that was
your idea uh i was working on it with
two other co-founders
all right at what point did you realize
it failed that you're just like this
isn't working we gotta pull the plug on
it
uh we pretty much got
not too many we didn't get that many
companies paying for it and then we got
a lot of pushback so it didn't
really make sense we ended up doing a
quick pivot to
a marketing automation tool that allowed
you to
automate a lot of your interactions
online so imagine if someone tweeted
something specifically to you on twitter
it would respond with a very specific
thing
uh but then twitter does not really like
people developing on their api so that
got shut down pretty quickly too and
then after that it was pretty much okay
let's wind down the company got it and
then what was the second business second
business was
peer-to-peer lending uh to people
attending coding boot camps so in san
francisco and just pretty much
everywhere there's a lot of coding
bootcamps that have popped up the idea
being that it's 20 30 000
in order to go through the program but
they're helping you increase your income
dramatically so people making maybe 40
to 60 000
are now making 90 to 150 000 a year so
how do you get more people into these
programs because you're empowering them
but a lot of the times they don't have
twenty thousand dollars it's and even if
they do like is this a good investment
so can you lend based off the idea that
if they go through this program that
they're going to be very safe and like
risk less comparably
got it what do you take as collateral if
anything like what's to say that you
lend them 30k
they get a day before graduating they
just like you know what i'm over it or
they don't apply themselves afterwards
they don't get a job like is it the same
as like a credit card where it's like
it's an unsecured loan then you have to
go after them yeah it was unsecured i
think that was another part of the
problem where
you it's really hard to underwrite
people who are unsecured without any
other assets and even if you do chase
them even if you can it's not the best
look that a company is trying to chase
down students
say i would do that i'd chase them down
i would not every night they'd get a
phone call from me where's my money yeah
it's great hey what's up what's up guys
it's graham here you owe me money yeah
uh so that one ended up getting aqua
hired by a firm
uh which is the lending company max
levchin's a firm a firm yeah a firm
affirmative e-f-f-i-r-m but it was an
aqua hire so one a firm affirmative firm
that's been doing really well yes wow
[Music]
i see so when you say aqua what is that
so aqua hire basically means
so one trick when you look at
acquisitions is if there's no number
assigned to it then it's generally
something super tiny where either
investors get paid back or just maybe
you get a bit of money but not a lot so
like if you see an acquisition say oh
they're required but nothing versus oh
they required for 250 million or
something so what are we talking here so
well no my my assumption then it sounds
like whatever money you had in to paid
out the investors so you've got to break
it but then you continue to work for the
company um
no one none of the founders did
they basically bought uh the users that
we had on the platform and the marketing
collateral that we had imagine a firm
buy now pay later for uh like tuition
imagine that i think they tried that
space for quite a bit but it got really
tough and it just the other problem was
that there was another startup that
popped up called lambda school which was
doing it internally so what they did was
they would have you go through their own
program and instead of lending you money
it was
income it was a
income share agreement so they would
take a certain percentage of their money
until it hit 30 000 for the next two
years so it's like well you don't need
to lend the money there's no risk why
would you take on any risk at all when
you can do an income share agreement got
it i like that better okay
so that got acquired then what was next
next i pretty much hopped around a few
different startups that i was interested
in and just helping out as an early
employee okay when'd you make the
youtube channel youtube channel was when
the chase sapphire reserve came out
wow that was what 2016 i believe yeah
2016 i was very hesitant until i think i
saw beat the bush had like an audience
yeah and then
maybe you mentioned this too at some
point that like beat the bush like
was why you considered starting that
there was an audience yeah yeah speaking
of which beat the bush is coming this uh
upcoming not yet a week from tomorrow
really excited beat the bush i've been
watching his channel since probably
2016. he's one of the first channels to
talk about financial independence retire
early and i remember his always his
videos would get like 10 000 views a
video that he would talk about fire i
was like wow there's ten thousand people
out there
and uh yeah
he he was a great example that you could
make a video about that and if there's
an audience for it yeah i was surprised
because i think when i thought of
youtube it's entertainment it's more
like comedy skits or music versus
yeah yeah education so yeah the chase
sapphire reserve that was the card for
me that really got me like gung-ho about
credit cards prior to that for me it was
the amex gold and i loved that card
because i think it got 30 000 35 000
points i think when i signed up and then
i used uh 25 000 of those points for a
round-trip plane ticket to go and visit
family in canada and then i realized wow
this is so cool so then i'd like refer
family and friends uh to get the car to
i get 5 000 points of referral and
we basically load those up and get free
free free trips so ever since i think it
was like 2013 never paid for a plane
ticket i've always just used points
wow i have no idea yeah you don't travel
that much
granted yeah
and i haven't traveled ever so i've
never paid for a plane ticket but no the
chase fire reserve for me was uh was the
card that came out that i felt like i
had finally made it because it was metal
and i remember getting that card it was
one of the first people to get it as
soon as it came out and it was a metal
credit card and i was blown away i got a
hundred thousand points for signing up
to this card and i was just ecstatic
what was your limit on that card do you
remember thirty
thirty five thousand dollars i think
thirty two thirty yeah it was thirty two
or thirty five thousand uh that would i
would have been 25 i think
wait it came out 2016. yeah 25 26. i
don't uh you know it came out just after
i turned 26. a lot a lot of people
started with like 15 to like 35k is that
like pretty common
geez i did not know that the limit was
that high yeah
we got like 3 000 on my card which card
kind of on my cards i don't have the the
so the difference though is that
something like the chase sapphire
reserve the minimum starting limit is
ten thousand dollars so like if they if
they are uncomfortable giving you ten
thousand they're gonna be like
yeah yeah yeah please go over there got
it okay yeah let's go with the discover
it's secured card yeah
now but that that card for me was it got
me so excited about cards that really
got me interested in the doctor of
credit i got really into the points guy
like all of his people uh through the
chase sapphire reserve and i actually
applied at the same time as a chase
sapphire reserve i also applied for the
chase sapphire preferred
and then i think there was one or two
other cards i got at the exact same time
because it's right in the middle of a
renovation
and the contractor asked if i wanted to
put the materials on the card or just
lump that in with his payment i'm like
now we're gonna put it on the card so i
basically got like three or four credit
cards charged like four grand four grand
four i just maxed them all out will not
max it but the for the sign up
and then i got hundreds of thousands of
points that's a way for money yeah i
know but that's what i recommend yes
like half the time it's like if you
you're doing a deck
renovation or anything where you spend a
large amount of money weddings are
another big one where hey i'm dropping
thirty thousand dollars and if you if
you're gonna if you're gonna do that
anyways and like let's say your
significant other wants that then why
not get the honeymoon for free or highly
highly subsidized yeah so what are your
thoughts on how much to spend on a
wedding
you told me 30 grand i'm like 30 000.
yeah i don't thousand dollars i don't
think i would spend that much i think
i don't know for me
it would be five or ten thousand dollars
would be fine i would rather save that
money and either travel with it or like
invest it or do anything else versus
putting on a show for a bunch of people
is my view is there any way that you can
say that an event to all like the
vendors is not a wedding because i know
for a fact once you tell the vendors
that you're having a wedding they
immediately charge like a 100 premium on
their services so if you just say oh
yeah it's just like a business party
with all my friends and then boom
there's a bride in the groom
you probably could get away with it well
i used to own a wedding company jack
oh and um that happened to me once
how did it make you feel as a vendor
yeah i hated those people
listen but you gave them a fair rate
right for your service we put in so much
more attention to detail for weddings i
mean the planning is just crazy so
alex said it's true so i read an entire
thread on reddit about this where
someone was asked like how do i save
money on a wedding and everyone was
giving their tips and tricks and one of
the the first thing for the dj was don't
tell them it's a wedding
and they'll quote half the price same
with catering don't tell them it's a
wedding and uh the one guy who commented
was a photographer
and said uh he's walked away from events
like that where they told them it's like
we're just hosting an event just take
pictures
uh because like alex said the the
attention to detail for a wedding
is
significantly more important than uh
like like you know you're just drinking
with your butts you know to get those
shots and and to have that such a like a
one-time occasion you can't mess up
and so not that they're going to mess up
anyway but it's like instead of taking
pictures of you know i was just thinking
for the venue and maybe for the food
services not that i think the
photographer is very important that they
do know it's a wedding yes um yeah
people have said for the venue don't
it's a wedding but i think they they
would it's basically really frowned upon
but i agree listen i agree with that you
know how much do you think you're gonna
you should spend on a wedding
uh
ten thousand sounds sounds that's pretty
reasonable i listen on a ring here's the
thing
well it if i think if it if it were my
choice like if if we're doing like my
choice here i i think like five thousand
bucks like in my mind just just like
right now yeah but like i would say like
rent out a warehouse space or something
like that like a cool warehouse
uh had you know you could get a lot of
the stuff like that dj just get that
sponsored or whatever uh i think that's
the food you could save people over the
house it's like you know something like
that potluck would you do it would you
do a youtube wedding
uh probably not probably not no i didn't
want to want this
yeah i doubt it but um no i don't know
it just seems like
it's just this throw a party five grand
yeah like five grand i honestly think
five grand throw a party right yeah you
could rent a mansion for probably like
three thousand yeah four thousand that's
it just yeah exactly get get the food so
all you need to do is just get food
delivered right invite people and that's
it right domino's delivery
that's easy fancy that's event but
something like that you know i i don't
get the
theatrics i i but i i just that's the
main issue is a lot of people feel that
that's the absolute peak and best point
of their life that's why they want it to
be amazing but then that's kind of sad
and that's why i think about that the
rest of your life is downhill from here
yeah i also think there's like very
diminishing returns once you're at like
twenty thousand versus thirty thousand
or even like up to two hundred k right
it's like how much
how much more then it's usually for the
family then it's really like but i feel
i don't know i can't help but feel like
a lot of that seems very superficial of
just like let's let's impress i think
it's flexible
yeah is it really i think it's flexing
for a certain demographic yeah
like some people do luxury watches and
cars and other people do fancy weddings
that's yeah that's true it's just
another flex listen if people are
spending 300 grand on an nft just to be
like that's true yeah
ultra wealthy yeah but here's the thing
even in an nft it'll still retain its
value i feel like
it's it's hard it's hard to well then
again you you know then you get into
like what's the memory word sure i don't
know like i look at some of these things
like like people are spending like 15
000 a bottle service
and i'm like well i'll have a better
memory just going and watching uh you
know some documentary on youtube
and uh just relaxing like that that's a
that's a great night for me i have a
great memory from that we're just going
to super sushi right yeah it's a great
memory like so my memory to price ratio
is very low
so that's how it is what do you think
you said ten thousand dollars is a
proper amount to spend on a wedding i
mean i that's for me and
that's what i would be comfortable with
but i would probably do a different
thing than you i'd probably just fly
immediate family out to like hawaii or
something and then try to use points to
subsidize other stuff see that's a good
wedding yeah versus like throwing a
party for maybe a lot of people and some
of them i don't actually care about yeah
yeah i like that idea i know this is
kind of a tangent but you said like
material things such as like watches or
fancy cars are you a person that that
likes stuff like that um i have
ironically we ordered a snoopy 50th
edition omega watch last year that we
were supposed to get this year so it's
like a collectible watch um
it was ten thousand dollars but like the
secondary market for it is like 50 to
like 70 dollars yeah right snoopy
watching
you bought it for ten and now it's worth
50 to 70. you haven't gotten it yet i
haven't gotten anything yeah that's
probably why i'm not a vip that's why i
see that's why i'm down the list so how
did you get it immediately though i
didn't get immediately i just put my
name i kept every time i came to vegas i
would go to the shop and ask to put my
name on the list and every time they'd
be like we don't have a list that watch
does not exist right and then one time
they're like we do have that list and
we're taking deposits and it's like if
you pay in full then and you know
you will get it though yes eventually so
the question is i don't know how long i
don't like that eventually because by
the time you get it yeah it's going to
value my tank everyone else is going to
get there
exactly i've heard
i don't want to say names i've heard bad
things about going to the watch places
on the strip
because they don't take you serious
because they they just see you as like
in and out yeah oh that's another one of
these guys yeah yeah yeah um they want
the locals to go in there because those
are repeat business a lot of people go
to the strip
rarely come back or not that often so
i've heard not so good things about you
want to go to someone local yeah on that
or
federico talks watches he's good he's
great yeah yeah what would you say is
your most lavish expenditure
um i think travel travel yeah so even
though i have a lot of credit card
points and stuff there's a lot of trips
i don't use points for because the
value's not there got it yeah
we could also mention why you're in town
right can't we i think we should first
talk about your youtube channel so you
started the youtube channel 2016 chase
sapphire reserve mm-hmm did you do that
to make money or was that just you were
excited about talking about credit cards
so i could not shut up about credit
cards is what happened i think once you
get into the rabbit hole you're like
guys just why is no one else signing up
for this it's 100 000 points it's
literally free money and people are like
man let me think about it so i was
trying to convince a few friends to sign
up for the card and back then there
wasn't even a referral link so it's like
just sign up it makes you money and then
i i had to repeat it so many times that
i'm like let me just film a video you
can watch it as many times as you want
because they kept asking me the same
questions and that kind of started
everything and
initially i wasn't really sure if i even
could make money on youtube i don't
think most people come in to thinking
about that a lot of it is just educating
other people and
i don't know just talking shop about
something you're interested in
that's interesting you still work in a
full-time job at that point making
youtube how many videos are you posting
in the beginning beginning i think we
did like one a month and then
at uh at some point
the startup that i was working at ended
up
shutting down pretty much so running out
of money um and then i started doing
dailies in 2017 i think starting in
march and was that
seen as a replacement to your job um i'm
not even sure if we were monetized yet i
think i was just like let's see what
happens and do this and
see where it goes got it now you
obviously had the savings right to get
yourself through this in the beginning
yeah at what point did you realize that
youtube is now a career or that you
wanted to do that full-time
i think towards
the fall of 2017
when we were starting to make more money
and
i get monetized for a lot of stuff
yeah
so can you break down a few of the
income sources obviously you have ad
revenue
uh credit card affiliates could you
break it down
um i would say
i would say youtube
adsense is probably only about like 10
to 20 percent
[Music]
sponsorships are probably about
20
and then affiliate is the rest
that's fan that's fantastic to have
affiliate that much uh could you could
you tell us any just generally yeah what
are you bringing in per month
it's like highs
it's it's like mid to highest five
figures
per month per month yeah
so
but about a million a year give give or
take plus or minus depending if the irs
is watching or not right yes oh yeah
that's fantastic and and has that been
pretty consistent
uh no it's highly cyclical depending on
the cards that come out and
everything else so with 2020 we pretty
much had like six months of like
terribleness because all the issuers
were pulling back and they were not uh
either having bonuses or they were not
paying out and yeah everything related
to that side was terrible yeah i
remember i got worried that uh it was
the last month of march i think i got
not like worried worried but uh my ad
revenue went down i think it was 80 70
80
almost overnight when that when
everything was going down 80 was gone
like the next day and then
i had sponsorships that were kind of in
the works like they're kind of talking
about everyone was like all right we're
holding off for a little bit and so for
that for that month
it was like ah crap is this going to be
like the new normal uh is it's just like
80 was gone views were really down too
at that ti at that time i don't know why
but uh and then everything a month later
just
went crazy it was nuts well that's great
i think that year like dependent on
credit cards like although that sounds
kind of like a negative thing we like
the content you make graham is
basically just upon like investing
principles which don't change over time
so it's pretty tough to create content
but for you you have like a recurring
thing that you can continue to make
content on it's always good content you
probably have a really good formula for
each video so i'm sure that's probably
quite nice kind of like the doug demiro
of chris exactly that's right yeah yeah
yeah i think with yours it's really easy
to get a lot of views and get a lot of
adsense because it's like oh the
market's turning and it works out really
well because you can do general news now
i think for me uh my
total addressable market is
substantially smaller even when i talk
about general finance stuff it actually
doesn't do well for my channel yeah so
because my audience is so trained to
only expect credit card stuff yeah
i always thought it was kind of funny
that you and uh the credit shifu were
always neck and neck with subscribers
i've seen you like you gain a thousand
he gains a thousand he gains a thousand
you get a thousand uh what's the
relationship like between you two um
friendly i'm he's cool is there any
rivalry that goes on like you see him
make a video and you're like oh he got
to that video first
uh sometimes i think he's really good
about getting stuff out fast because he
used to be like a news reporter person
so he's like really good on camera
i'm a bit more shaky because as you can
see with the intro i end up repeating
parts a lot until i like find the one
that i like but he's like he's kind of
like heaven in that sense where he can
just do it in one take got it yeah i
repeat myself so most of my videos me
saying the same thing 10 times and then
i'll pick that last one that's exactly
what i do which is the worst and i need
to get better off that yeah yeah so when
did you get into startup investing
because that's what i find the most
interesting yeah so i think in 2020 when
everything was slowing down
and
actually let's rewind so in 2019 we
traveled once a month every month and we
were expecting to do that in 2020 as
well i actually considered being a
digital nomad in 2020 which obviously
didn't work out and once we started
staying in the bay area more just
hanging out with more friends that we
knew who were doing startups and said
hey this is pretty cool i have some
disposable investments i didn't really
know where i want to put it and
startup investing seems interesting and
it seemed a lot more affordable than i
thought and a lot of people come into
startup investing say thinking that they
need to put in like a hundred thousand
dollars or like even fifty thousand
dollars into deals but a lot of
companies will happily take you if you
can add value now if an investment
doesn't do well what do you what do you
like what's the definition if it if it
how do you know if it does well or not
so you can kind of tell by whether first
off they tell you it's gonna they're out
of money and it's like hey do you want
to put in more money and that's always a
concern
secondly if they don't raise any
additional rounds in let's say a year
that's generally a big sign because most
startups raise with the expectation that
they have to raise again in six to 18
months
how many startups have you invested in
probably
85-ish but a lot of small checks too
like some some of the bigger ones i just
put like a 2 500 check-in
well in some of the smaller ones yeah
some i know some of the bigger ones
bigger companies that don't want funds
uh yeah exactly so like there are some
companies that are in like 100 or 200
million valuation range and
like i know that the upside there is
lower therefore i just put in less money
but i think it's still going to do well
like i think it can 10x but what's the
point though of a 2500 investment
well it's just like investing like
pre-ipo right yeah so the idea is that
you can still 10x to
50x and if you look at the s p or like
any of these other exchanges
look at how much value is within tech
companies compared to everything else so
like if you look at like facebook
microsoft google amazon and i think
netflix represents 20 of the s p
so
assuming
assuming that you are very bullish on
tech why not get into it earlier and if
you look at these hedge funds and these
other investment vehicles they're
actually looking more early stage now so
traditionally they never touched
venture capital stuff because that
wasn't their business but they're
looking for alpha they're looking for
income and how to make more money so
startups is that next stage to me yeah
but why 2500 why not 10k 15k why
think a lot of it is diversification and
with startup investing you want to
diversify and then sometimes it's just
building a relationship with founders so
even if you're not necessarily super
duper bullish but you think they'll do
okay you might still want to invest to
have that relationship because you think
their next startup is going to be the
banger got it and what do you look for
in a startup specifically
so generally there's like three things
you want to consider you want to
consider the team
traction and then the product
um as long as you have two of those
three things they're pretty good to go
so you want to see if that they have a
competitive advantage
and can beat out other people
the problem is that i've seen so many
startups that either you've given me or
that that other people have given me in
the network and i think they're stupid
ideas i hear them and i think that is
like an idiot would have to do that
and then
a year later i see that they've 10xed in
value
i'm like why
how how it doesn't make any sense there
was a there was a startup that that me
and kevin
both listened through
this in my i'm gonna say what it is it
was the equivalent of like a college
presentation i thought it was so bad and
these are just like
adults doing this thing it's a stupid
idea
and
like 5x but no no but but here's the
thing
you can't really cash out it's not like
it'd be like sell right now like you
have to see it through completions you
know but
why it doesn't make sense if i'm passing
on some of these ideas
so the question though is
is your background conducive to
understanding what the future is right
yeah
but that was something i was directly
involved in okay no but i mean do you
basically do you think you're the oracle
of the future
like do you is yours
what
is your view you're saying that on
record listen there there's there's this
idea well it's all to say it's in real
estate it's a real estate company oh
wait a minute is this the one you told
me about no oh
no that was another one um but i like
that one that one was good yeah it was
good uh but no the real estate one
i can't see how this would i couldn't
see it yeah just as someone who's been
in the business yeah so you're the
oracle of of real estate in the future
for that idea yeah
i mean to be fair there was another one
that you presented to me that 10x which
one the credit card one that pay your
rent with your credit card did you
invest in that i did not did you
you did this this is for a spot
yeah so that's how well let me tell you
let me tell you what happened it's a uh
a lesson to everybody okay did you learn
about this from
what who did you learn about this
investment from kevin o'leary and what
and and you didn't trust him i did
oh all right
you're speaking as though i i've do you
know what i'm going to say but you don't
i thought you were you were going to say
that you brought him the deal that's why
you're no no no no no
kevin o'leary uh introduced me i'm not
going to say it um kevin o'leary
introduced me to a company that i liked
they were good um so i put money into
this and got it all signed uh through
angel invest and i got an email said
congratulations your deposit has been
received all the stars are great stuff
fine
um
they sent me an email a follow-up to
finalize like they wanted me to sign
something
i missed the email i don't know they
emailed me again a few weeks later
i missed the email uh and i get like
hundreds of emails a day so it's like
you know sometimes i sift through or
sometimes i'll even see somebody like oh
i need to get to that and then by the
time like i just the day has gone by i
forget about it uh then he uh the the
the founder sends me a text
and it was like in the middle i i must
have been filming or something sometimes
i'll open up the text and just like i'll
get to it later i forget about it and
gosh almost a year later now got back to
me and said hey graham like i want to
let you know we're uh we're raising
another round like 400 million dollars
like some absurd amount
and uh he asked me if i wanted to get in
i say well you know i just my my initial
invest and he always says like it's too
bad we weren't able to get you into the
first round
and i was like wait what no i and i
showed him the email is like
i submitted i i'm in there i signed
everything it's like no you missed this
one email and we weren't able to get you
through that round
and he's like we've been trying and sure
enough i looked back and uh he was
telling the truth like sure enough
he they said that they were trying to
reach out it was that was on me
but uh my investment would have gone up
like 15 times yep had i had that
investment gone through it was it was uh
you know not like six figures or
anything like that but but
it was it was an amount that like
just it's tough yeah so they wanted to
do a make good and we're still trying to
work that out um
at that value you know at the original
valuation if i could do something uh add
some value there but still
yeah but but you didn't invest in that
yes why i skipped that one because i was
not
it was something that i did not feel
comfortable pushing
on my channel so i think a lot of my
investments aren't necessarily only
fintech but it's what do i feel
comfortable recommending to a friend and
at that point from what i heard at least
it didn't seem like it was that thing
and that's why i was like oh it probably
will do super well but if i don't if i
either i can't help them or if i don't
feel comfortable recommending it do i
really want to invest in it yeah was it
you that explained to me by the way that
uh their valuation is the likelihood
that they're gonna reach a billion
dollars was that you that told me that i
probably think i did yeah
uh because i was asking sebby i said
like how do they come up with these
values it seems like very arbitrary
numbers like big numbers 100 million 20
million and it must have been you that
explained
if they're raising a hundred million
dollars that means investors think
there's a 10 chance that they're going
to hit a billion
if they're raising at uh 500 million
there's a 50 chance they're going to hit
a billion kind of makes sense
that's that's kind of the metric now the
valuations have actually shifted more i
would say the starting valuations
uh went from something like maybe five
mil to eight mil to
15 to like 30 ml is pretty standard now
for even pre-product
so it just depends on your team and
everything are you worried about that
because the credit card i think that was
a 15 to 30 million dollar evaluation
without a product a ma imagine this jack
imagine not even having a product
and your companies are 30 million
dollars
it doesn't make sense how does how you
betting on the team though
you're betting on the fact that they
have the right relationships to make it
work long term so that they're either
well connected enough or that they have
the smart people in the room to make the
right decisions
but why even raised that like i feel a
lot of these things
shouldn't they still financially
self-funded like why it seems to me
like it's an easy way to come up with
these
you know we came up with this idea it's
100 million dollars maybe it's actually
worth 10. but let's say it's 100 million
we're gonna raise all this capital we're
gonna barely give up anything but now we
got like all this money a lot of it is
on
basically showing that other people
believe in you so even if you can
self-finance it if people don't believe
in you then it's a bit tougher and then
another part of it is relationship
building so by having someone as an
investor then they're more likely to
talk about you and connect you with the
right people
wow so you're saying if i self-funded
something and i got it to a business
let's say it's making like three million
dollars a year in profit let's say it's
worth 15
that it would be more difficult for me
to raise capital than at the very
beginning
just having
no people on my side not necessarily but
i'm just saying
the case for you selling some of that
equity early on is that you might be
getting more people on your team to help
you so maybe instead of just going from
three mil maybe by having that extra
capital you maybe get to 9 mil so it's
like reinvesting in your set
or you're filming equipment or anything
else like that
so the question then becomes you're
you're investing in a lot of these
you have the connections
why don't you do it why don't i do the
startup instead why don't you do a
startup instead ironically we actually
oh okay sorry so ironically we actually
are doing a startup right now mandy and
i
can we hear about it
so what we're doing is we're creating a
platform that allows content creators to
get equity in startups for early stage
deals so when you think of the robin
hood of robin hoods of the world when
they first started when they were worth
substantially less they weren't paying
out as much because they couldn't afford
it because we're just a startup and we
can't pay you that much but if you got
equity even five dollars in equity at
that point that probably would be worth
500 to maybe a thousand dollars per
share and yes they're starting to pay
you more now but that's not really
what's happening yeah so this guy sent
me an email pre-ipo investing partner
opportunity
managed shady already sorry yeah okay
uh so he says i have a new partnership
opportunity that may be of interest to
you link to allow accredited investors
to invest in pre-ipo shares of a variety
of companies in the past they allow
investors to get in early companies like
sofi robin hood and coinbase at 35
dollars a share and currently now for
investments in companies like kraken
ripple
uh varro impossible foods and zipline a
logistics company uh for referrals to
complete the full sign up process the
program will pay you 360
so is is is that basically
no so that's more you investing money
this is more so
pretty much the
what we did with the other fintech
startup wow so this is so service we're
talking about
social capital
yes wow
so okay
that's it so tell us more
so yeah
um basically
how do you help these early stage
companies who don't have the war chest
of robin hood and instead of giving you
cash like the five dollars maybe doesn't
move the needle
but what about five dollars in equity
because it could be worth substantially
more
yeah
the one issue that uh that i want to say
because i've um
really yeah ever since about a year and
a half ago i just wanted equity
and so every time a company would reach
out to me not every time but a lot of
the time when i really really really
like the company it's like can you just
give me equity instead you give me less
money but just i just want the equity
and almost all of them said no
because first of all it didn't seem like
they had an issue getting people just
like hey we're just going to pay you and
that's good but the the bigger thing
when i when i spoke with some of the
larger companies was that they don't
want to give up their equity it's so
highly like
guarded that they don't they want to
keep all of it for themselves and not
only that but then it's
getting that approved through everybody
else and they're like well if we do it
through you then we have to go through
everybody so it seems so why
why is that and
and it seems also like
then once i started saying that all the
great companies don't want to give up
equity then i'm skeptical of the
companies who do because then i'm like
well if they believed in it that much
then why wouldn't they just keep it for
themselves they must not believe it must
not be that good if they're giving me
equity
yeah so a lot of the companies that
you're probably asking for equity from
are way too late so if they're worth
more than 100 ml yes it's very unlikely
that they're going to do that because
they'd rather just raise more money
because capital's so cheap at that point
going from 10 mil to 100 million is a
lot harder than going from 100 million
to 1 billion so for them
there's so many people who want to hand
the money but in that early stage that's
where we can add the most value
generally and also where they might
benefit the most from actually else
shouting it out or us helping them with
any user acquisition so let's say you
bring me on what's the expectation of me
is it like i mention them so many times
a
month do i have an out on that like
what's the let's say there's a company
on there that you don't like you can
skip it and you can focus on the ones
that you do like and
uh the idea is that you can select and
you can see what the valuations are and
you in your head can see if it's worth
it for you to do it and
there's three different models that we
have so
it allows you to do it based off
conversions so pretty much like any
other affiliate link you'll be able to
just shout it out any point you want uh
any sponsor segments so instead of ten
thousand dollars in cash or five
thousand dollars in cash it's five
thousand dollars in equity because for
them that's maybe more affordable and
then advisory if they really want to sit
down with you and maybe pick your brain
once a week or something got it i'm
worried that it seems like a lot of
these companies
let's say they're valued at 10 right
and it seems like for the influencer
you're almost working against yourself
because now you shouted it out and now
that 10 goes to 20 very quickly and then
it's like well now if i do this shout
out again now i'm getting like deluded
i'm getting less value than i did the
first time when it was
how do you overcome that
and also how do you overcome the fact
that a lot of these companies since they
believe they're going up in value
instead of paying like 20 000 upfront
cash they'll be like we'll just give you
5k of equity but it's going to be worth
10 times that you know very soon
yeah i think that's always going to be
tough so you're looking for people who
believe in the company long term but i
think that is the trend that we're going
towards
and if you look at the really big
influencers if you look at the casey
neight stats the good mythical morning
guys a lot of them actually have funds
that invest in startups
and
for a lot of the people in the middle
let's say 100 000 to 1 million
subscribers you make a good amount of
money but you don't make enough that you
have a fund or that you're investing as
much as you would want so how do you
turn your capital or your social capital
into actual ownership
when is this going live
uh it actually already is live if you
wanna sign up if you're a creator why
don't we do that with the iced coffee
hour
can we do that as the iced coffee hour
yup
okay can we do it with this the family
it doesn't have 100 000 subscribers okay
i'll reach back out to you later wait
dude we don't need a hundred thousand
subscribers i didn't know
i i trust you yeah oh yeah
why don't we do that all right let's do
it yeah really i think it's a great idea
uh
and the idea too is that if you don't
have a sponsor segment then why not
have an affiliate it's pretty much
exactly the same as weeble and that you
can plug it in however you want do we
have a sponsor
uh not for this one but guys sign up for
the thing in the description
whatever whatever the thing is it's
really good check it out we love it it's
amazing okay no excuse me whatever it is
uh this is the company that jack and i
have gone through we've been working on
it for a long time very long time no no
we'll go through the list we'll pick
we'll pick like one or two that we
really like
and that'll be down below in the
description but we gotta get on this
episode's posting on sunday so the time
is a ticking right we got it we got to
get on this limited sign ups only
limited to 100 people 24 hours yeah
about this we're going to take the link
down in 24 hours if you don't do it now
yeah i like the idea yeah signing up
how many startups have you exited like
cashed out of so far none of them so
right now it's all paper money so even
if
yeah even if i have like oh two million
or five million in like net worth it's
all paper money can you can you tell us
the aggregate value let's say of the
worth of the startups right now just
draw us a number
um
so mandy and i put about
a million into startups okay i put like
four or something
um i would say it's about like 10x
a lot of it's like paper money right
okay so i got 10 million yeah like
there's one startup i put 5k in that 20
something yet so it's worth like yeah
can you tell us what startup that is no
so the the one thing that a lot of
people hate about startup stuff is
that it's so private because it's not my
choice because if i do it then i'm going
to get cancelled by the founder and
because they're like hey don't like
don't explain this don't explain
validation don't do a press release yet
so oftentimes when people do talk about
them investing in something everyone
does it on the same exact day and people
are like oh is this a scam that the
youtubers are doing because they're all
announcing their investors it's like no
because that was the day it's publicized
i think it's old that's a stupid
old-school rule i don't i mean i don't
get it just talk about it when you want
to talk about it yeah i think it's it's
the old and the new balancing act got it
that's it's 10 mil so are you nervous
that that there's a chance that many of
these pan out or like what what are the
chances that some something reaches 100
million dollars and it fails
um
10 right yeah yeah i think it can still
obviously happen i think
to me 10 mil is the 100 mils to range
where it gets a lot easier to raise
capital because your fundamentals are
there now it's just based off your
numbers and your performance
but let's just say it's 100 mil is there
ever a chance that they're just like hey
we're done 100 and no one buys them out
because wouldn't they at least wouldn't
they always have some sort of worth
giving their like couldn't they always
be like all right guys like we're
selling back we're selling at 20 million
now yeah so assuming it is not a scam
and there's no legal issues in the
background
oftentimes you'll probably have someone
buying them at pennies on the dollar or
at least enough for investors to get
their money back so we've seen that a
lot where like a company might raise a
hundred mill at uh 800 million valuation
but then they get bought for like 200
mil so it's like the investors get paid
back the employees get a bit and the
founders get a bid and the idea is that
they lock you in so that team has to
work for that company for like four
years otherwise you don't get your money
yeah got it
so since we're talking about startups i
want to ask you about this okay so uh as
we know very good friends with jeremy
financial education he's seen the future
as
creating his own app because right now
you know uh we're relying on all these
other websites for our information his
idea was we have the audience uh why
don't we create our own product why are
we investing in all these other things
when we could just do it ourselves and
create something that's very uh to us
what were you about to say i feel like a
lot of people have tried that and it
makes sense but it's so tough to port
your audience somewhere else if you look
at people's views like how often to use
certain apps it's all in the mainstream
apps um but it's just really tough to
get people off of tick tock instagram
facebook youtube okay
let me tell you about this app i need
brutal honesty with you okay brutal okay
the app is called the hungry bowl down
below in the description if you want to
try it out follow along with us
but the goal of it originally was that
we were big fans of morning brew like
big fans uh but we knew we could never
compete with morningbrew with an email
they've got the email down everyone who
does that now is a copycat so
immediately we're off of that
um we came up with the idea of doing it
in an app because that way once someone
downloads an app they're never gonna
delete that app i have apps on my phone
that i've had for years i'll just never
delete it the other thing that that's
really good with an app unlike emails
that you can control who gets
notifications i know with email
sometimes uh it gets lost tickets and
spam sometimes it don't get sent
whatever it is with an app you download
it you get a notification so we've
created our newsletter
um
on that app that'll send you a
notification
and then we realized well we're not just
going to make an app with the newsletter
so we also integrated
stock charts earnings reports sec
reports everything in one place so
basically just aggregates all the
information from around the internet uh
that you just click a few buttons and
everything is there and then it became
well we would love for it to integrate
all of your stocks so like let's say you
have like five shares of tesla on weeble
five shares in public five shares on uh
robin hood
it could aggregate all that and show on
the hungary bowl you have 15 shares
because it always bothered me that you
had to like look you know attention
and mint does it horribly so we want to
integrate that and like do like paper
trading and just a few other things on
the app
uh it's very expensive
and hearing about uh first of all how
long it takes and how much it costs to
build something like that out
it's
extremely expensive i don't think people
realize uh including integration if you
wanna
raise money
yes so i wanna show you the app
and then i want your honest advice
uh the color scheme looks a bit
tacky to me i'd probably use like some
flat colors or just yeah different
colors but it's fine
um it just feels like there's not really
much to do like it kind of feels like a
watered-down weeble or like any of those
other things where they have this as a
future and then long-term the other
question is well how are you actually
monetizing this like with weeble it's
because
they have all this other these other
things that this is a service that
they're adding on top to add value but
like if this is the core thing it's like
are you charging
people to use this app are you selling
the information are you just aggregating
it so i think that's a big question
the plan was sponsorships within the
newsletter
or affiliates personally
uh i don't think the affiliates will
convert
and um
morningbrew does really really really
well with their sponsors but they also
have
millions of people yep on a daily basis
yeah and then i think
i mean i think it's okay
it's just convincing people to sign up
for another app but if you have creators
doing it then it simplifies it a lot
more
i don't know i just don't think there's
any i don't think i would download this
or i think i would download it i'd be
like oh it's cool but i would never
go back to it and i get like a lot of
notifications on my phone about stuff
and i just ignore it or sometimes like
if it gets very annoying i'll just turn
off notifications
but yeah i won't uninstall that app got
it so on average uh what has it been two
years you've been in investing in
startups did you say yeah i would say
about two years two years and you've got
about a hundred percent return
no 10x i'm sorry sorry a thousand
percent return
yeah yeah but it's all paper returns
though that's the thing right so like it
either could be zero or it could keep
going up right i don't really know so
how much do you have invested in public
companies public companies i've lowered
my coverage pretty substantially i don't
know i just and again this is probably a
bad opinion but i'm not sure how much
higher it can go
so i would say like
two hundred thousand yeah
you sound like all of the people who
comment on my video we're at the peak
now and then i have another 20 percent
and then it keeps going up
uh i'm not shorting the market yeah
that's right yeah yeah but doesn't it
worry you a little bit that uh
evaluations are are
crazy that it seems like
for tech and i've spoken with a few
people who are in there and they're like
yeah now we're raising capital because
it's so easy right now and we're getting
crazy so like we'd be stupid not to
raise capital doesn't that concern you
that like
these conditions are just
how much higher could go so like as you
say that about the stock market i say
that about tech it's like how much
higher could go if interest rates go up
how is that going to impact all these
companies yeah definitely so i think
what i would look into is actually where
some of the other smart money is going
so if you look at hedge funds
a lot of them have started doing early
stage investing or at least like
mid-stage startup investing so in the
100 million dollar range because that's
where they see the returns and
ironically that's actually what's
pushing the valuations up because
there's new capital that didn't play in
this arena before that is starting to do
it and that's those are the people who
are pretty much doing a deal every two
days you know what i'm wondering if
people look at the stock market and
they're like yeah stocks are kind of
high we're gonna make more money and
they're looking at uh startups be like
wait a second everyone's getting a 10x
return there in two years let me just go
and do that and then that's caught that
self no it's self fulfilling because
there you so i'm seeing you do that and
i'm like i want some of that and then
sebby sees me doing that he's like i
want some of that and everyone else is
doing that i mean it's definitely a risk
uh one one thing a lot of people compare
it to is like the dot-com bubble and say
oh how do we know it's not that again
one thing to consider is back then there
were i think 400 million people who had
internet access and now it's closer to
something like 5 billion people so it's
like 10 times as many people and i don't
know i'm i'm pretty old now compared to
jack i feel like we're in the same age
group where i remember like having aol
floppy disks and cds to get free
internet and now everyone has everything
on their phone like you have instant
access to any information you want
yeah to me it always seems like the most
obscure ideas though um
are the ones that do the best i was
telling jack about this earlier that it
was always the things that were never
intended to make money that just grew
organically like i think morning brew
they started that uh in college as just
creating a newsletter for fun that they
would just work on this on the side and
would grow it it seems like those
businesses always tend to do the best
because you're never set out to do
anything and they just completely grow
on their own
yeah i think it it happens a lot to
other social apps where monetization is
not really the focus early on it's like
how do you grow as fast as possible and
then figure out monetization afterwards
yeah what was the one app that you were
telling me the guy remember we we went
on a run and and jack you told me about
this idea this guy that reached out to
you with a with a web browser extension
that i wanted to do that oh yeah
oh yeah okay so was it yeah it would no
no
and it turned into honey no it was this
it was this kid that was like in texas
or something studying at university and
he had developed an app with his friends
that uh it kind of like
like you'd put in a product i think and
then they find the cheapest place you
could buy that product so it's kind of
like honey where like you know they give
you the coupon code but ins instead it's
kind of like going in reverse image
searching something you want to buy and
that's that's what it did so you'd put
in the product and then i think that it
would reverse image search and obviously
it had like a database after you know
many people have done that
and then they'd show you where you could
buy it for the cheapest it was a genius
idea because i remember when i was
buying furniture for the duplex a while
ago every piece of furniture i would
reverse image search it find the same
thing for half the cost and i go through
that website and almost every single
item could reverse image search it and
find it somewhere else for cheaper
because they all use the same stock
image it's it's so silly but yeah this
extension i don't know if it's still up
or or not but yeah this extension would
you could turn it on and it would
automatically whatever you want to buy
reverse image search that image and then
find it cheaper
so long long-term you can see the path
to revenue because they can just take a
cut of that transaction right um short
term it's like can they figure out
distribution and even if it's a great
product if no one knows about it then it
doesn't really help
yeah yeah sounds like a pretty good
product yeah
i loved i loved the idea but i don't i
don't think he wanted an investor in
that i think he just wanted to share his
idea
but now so there you go now you got your
idea shared but i like i like that one a
lot so speaking about all this uh
lifestyle stuff do you own a house
no so we rent for now because
san francisco is prohibitively expensive
and also i don't think i want to put all
my capital into one thing i'd rather
diversify into a bunch of things
i think there's more like money to be
made more alpha
things so why live in california
yeah why not move to nevada or texas or
florida i think we've considered it but
for what we're trying to do with our
startup and also angel investing it's a
lot easier to network when you're in san
francisco because you can just go out
and grab a coffee of people like it's
it's a lot more convenient versus having
a fly over there and i think when you do
talk to people it's kind of stupid but
when you tell them that you're from san
francisco that you've worked in tech
they understand that you understand them
like you've been in the same position so
you have that relationship camaraderie
already versus someone like oh i'm in
i'm in dallas or something like i've
never i don't know what tech is i'm a
dentist but i want an angel invest
because i heard it on graham's podcast
then they're going to be like i don't
think i want to waste my time talking to
you i don't know how much value you can
add yeah got it but now the other thing
you have to consider too let's say you
have let's say your your 10 mil grows to
50. right
and if you you cash out of those in
california there goes 13
couldn't you move out like a as some of
those might be approaching like years in
advance you kind of get ahead a little
bit i think in the future it's probably
something we'll reevaluate right now
we're still growing the pie versus
worrying about like how how do i like
maximize how much i take but that's why
a lot of people have moved to miami and
that's been more of a tech hub recently
because of californians going over there
how many uh people in the tech industry
would you say have actually left
it's hard to say because i think there's
a lot of vocal people and it seems like
it's like 10 to 20 but i think if you
look at the stats it's closer to like
one to five percent a lot of influential
people left so a lot of the billionaires
who have made that money who've had like
five ipos this year left
do you think california would ever do a
wealth tax
or an exit tax i think it's been
proposed i i don't know if
i think it would scare too many people i
think it would actually potentially
destroy the state if they passed that
because then everyone would in the short
term it looks very good for them but
long term innovation's not going to
happen like a lot of people who
might be very successful want to build
big companies why build it here why not
vote it in like austin or anywhere else
now that you mentioned i realized you
have you kind of had the same outfit
very often why i think i have like 20 of
these shirts uh first off they're very
comfortable uh number two i just don't
wanna waste decisions every day so oh
wow so you're like steve jobs or
whatever who
sure zuckerberg does the same thing oh
zuckerberg yeah yeah yeah i think it's
just like i don't really care how i look
and i know that i look fine in this like
maybe there is something that i look
more fashionable in but like i'm not
trying to impress anyone so it doesn't
really matter and like most of my pants
are from lou lemon because they're
comfortable
yeah so pretty boring
do you think it helps or hurts you to
have a simple outfit in uh
in the bay area i feel like when you
walk around the bay area everyone's
wearing pataguchi patagonia or like
north face and just joggers like no
one's really dressed up like if you
compare it to la
i would say it's the polar opposite so
subby they mentioned that you were here
for something what are you here for i i
don't we never found out we're here for
the pokemon event
what is that planet
[Laughter]
it's a million dollar box breaking yeah
it's a million dollar box breaking of a
pokemon original first edition sound
yeah so the proceeds are going to i
believe the aoki foundation and to help
raise awareness for autism
so uh chris camelo i think donated one
of his boxes or actually donated like
two of his boxes that are worth like
three to five hundred thousand dollars
each just donated them and they're going
to be open tomorrow so it's going to be
a really exciting event and i think
we're going to be vlogging it so it's
going to be going to be incredible you
guys got to check out the family vlog
because we're going to post the whole
thing there but it's going to be an
incredible event
so what's rent like in san francisco
what are you guys paying um
if you can find you can find a
two-bedroom brand controlled for
3000
to 3500
which isn't too bad um if you want to do
super expensive obviously there's like
two bedrooms that are like seven or
eight thousand dollars a month as well
but yeah just depends on you what are
you guys what do you guys love it like
30 300 3200 wow that's not bad that's
not bad at all it seems like
you're probably saving like 80 of your
income right not most of it
and then the rest of it's just startups
yeah startup investing um some jpegs
no
no nft you doing nfts doing nfts are you
really are you making money no no
you're losing money in enemies
oh no i expected you to be like
i expected you to be buying like uh what
is it like angry apes or something yeah
yeah so what's going on
i bought a um of i bought like 100k of
top shot or 120k of nba topshop which is
dapper's thing uh that one's down like
20 but
yeah
um the other ones
are yeah other ones are kind of meh it's
it's hard to get a vibe on stuff too and
then like i'm trying to be like very
careful that i'm not accidentally like
perceived to be pumping stuff that's
another thing like we're like oh like i
might be doing something but it's like
don't necessarily just copy what i do
but yeah right it seems like
they're all big pump and dumps a lot of
them because it's
there there's there's some people out
there who always seem to be like
on the inn
like buy this it's about to it's about
to blow up and and they because they
they'll show it on just like on the
stories on instagram but just for
friends and they'd be like buy this buy
this buy now i've never gotten into nfts
but uh
i'm bullish on certain ones that are
community based so board apes art club
which i don't know absolutely that's the
app store club i am very bullish on
um and then
yeah any of the original ones that have
very strong communities so steph curry
and a lot of other nba players bought
board apes because the idea is that
they're going to make like these
locations in different cities where you
can go so if you don't have one of these
apes you either can't get in or you have
to be a guest of someone else so they're
making these like exclusive soho club
like places i didn't know that yeah
that's incredible that's the same one
and then a lot of it is the fact that
there's a discord so you don't have
access to that discord unless you have
one of these yes okay so that was one of
the things i found really interesting so
i follow alex becker on facebook i have
to say alex becker is
the best source of information i think
for nfts you might
maybe people disagree with me i've read
every single one of his posts
and he says that when people criticize
him for buying some of these really
expensive ones that are you know
hundreds of thousand dollars
he said
the discord group alone pays for that
because here's the thing imagine imagine
you spend uh like 500 grand on an nft on
a board and now you get access to a
discord group
you're not in a discord group with
people who have a million dollar net
worth
the people who buy those things 100
million dollars billion dollar net
worths
and now you're in a discord group
in the same community because of an nft
it's like having an inn to talk to these
people and network that's what it seems
like a lot of the value is
spending there's no other way for you to
likely talk to someone like steph curry
like even if
like people know you but certain people
at that level don't have a clue who you
are right so if this can get you access
to those people then that makes sense
ironically i was doing the opposite of
him so i was buying the ones and i
realized that those the ones are not
worth anything because it's it's like
yeah it's not going to go anywhere but i
would actually invest in the super
expensive good ones because those are
the ones that have value so
you think the ones with a community or
like or or being used as a token are
going to be worth something i think yes
very highly dependent on how good the
community is what do you think of crypto
punks crypto punks a lot of the perks is
the fact that there is that secret
community so in effect they're kind of
trying to be like the illuminati of tech
and i i'm pretty bullish on that one i
think i have like fractional ownership
of one like one like
thousand for some tiny amount of one so
i think that one's uh
pretty good and i think that can go
pretty far
a lot of people i know who are in web 3
who are bullish on nfts see the floor
for it being like 10 mil in like five to
10 years
per crypto punk yeah i talked to
somebody else
and uh they were convinced
that each crypto punk at minimum is
going to be worth a million dollars and
that's like the worst case scenario is a
million dollar crypto punk yeah i think
i've i've heard five to ten mil pretty
easily
it's just focusing on the blue chip ones
versus the ones that people are trying
to show on twitter so why don't you buy
a crypto punk i think it's too much
money into one asset that's the main
thing right like it's 500k into one yeah
one yeah but but it doesn't matter if if
the floor is going to be a mill to 10
million dollars let's just say yeah i
think i think a million i think is
reasonable honestly
uh why not just do it
because you could always sell it i think
it's just uh figuring out where
your
where the where
i think it's just figuring out where
it's best to put your money so for me
i'd rather just put a lot into a lot of
startups because that builds
relationships which helps with other
things and helps with our startup that
we're trying to do so yeah maybe in the
future i probably will try to buy one or
at least a fractional ownership of one
but even over i think fincon or
over one of the other events that we did
in the last two weeks we were talking
about like hey why don't like 10 of us
just
put in like 50k each to like buy 10
percent of one each or something yeah
i'd do that
i'll do that
yeah
i think i think some of these
communities that's where it's at i'm
just so worried it's it's hypey yeah and
just like these communities are are good
now
who's to say that you know the the
billionaire gets bored after a while
it's like
yeah
now all the plebs
bought in it's not good anymore
and that's the risk of it too that's why
it's like well would you really put 500k
into something like that right and then
also if the if anything happens to the
cryptocurrency market and like something
crashes
a lot of those if the bitcoin falls like
30 40
those nfts will probably fall 80 it'll
probably be double whatever bitcoin
might fall so thank you so much for
coming on i really appreciate it and for
all of you watching before you leave
just make sure to leave a leave a like
on the video that's it alex works so
hard behind the scenes to make this
possible
jack has to sit here the entire time
the least you could do give us a like
give us a subscribe we have uh
our link in the description on this
stuff
that we spent a lot of time looking
through
that'll be down below in the description
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time
cool 69.
nice